are you guys friends with Japanese all
my best friends are capitals
turns out Bernie Sanders isn't the only
socialist in America in fact there are
lots and some of them live amongst us
I'm about to go meet up with some right
now and see what they're all about and
if they can get down with the most booze
wah thing there is brunch I think most
Americans when they think about socials
and they think about like some dark
period in Russian history that most
people know nothing about but there's
some guy and he tells everybody what to
do and that's socialism and I'm not that
kind of guy the weirdest one is that
creates poor societies right I mean I
think in the best case social is creates
a rich society's time rich societies
societies in which you have like the
things you need to certain survive
unlike for example the one we live in
which where a lot of people don't have
those things
remember when old people used to be able
to retire I think this misconception is
that there'll be bread lines you know
from here or to wherever because we
don't have that now exactly right you
know and of course the history of how
socialism is contributed to the United
States is totally obscured really the
folks in the labor movements that were
pushing for an eight-hour workday
40-hour workweek the minimum wage things
basic things like that that we take for
granted now we're brought to us by
socialist socialists has room for lots
of different things there's not just one
kind of socialist my identity as a
socialist I think is less important as
helping people think of an alternative
reality that is plausible impossible and
radical that we can create
is the idea that socialism is a white
thing it's not true actually most people
who have tried to implement societies
that are critical of capitalism and in
the benefit of common people are people
of color black families Latino families
these socialist ideas that are
supposedly too difficult for people to
grasp people grasp them very quickly and
are there leading the change they're
thinking about how to organize society
around human development not just the
development of capital let me ask you
about like the word democratic social
it's like what is what does that mean
and why did Sanders for example to
clarify children become a democratic
socialism socialism fundamentally is
about expanding democracy right how so I
mean I think it's about creating
economic democracy I don't think what
Bernie wants to build is socialism or
socialist I think he wants to take some
ideas of socialism and apply them in a
capitalist context why do you think that
in the United States this is such a
dirty word socialism well there's a long
history of libertarianism in the u.s.
that I think it's kind of an issue like
individual freedom above all else Mulder
I kind of want collective freedom you
know like I want all women to be able to
have brunch when they want to and have
childcare rather than just for me to
have it but for me to have the personal
choice I mean I think there's been a
history of disparaging of the idea of
socialism by holding up some past
socialist experiments yeah
what if you guys like won the lottery
one day would you have to just get would
you give that money up immediately we
organize in such a way that we don't
have to depend on winning the lottery to
do what we want to do I guess
or like if I gave you a Ferrari would
you immediately just sell it no more I
sell it immediately
you sell it immediately no driving
around you wouldn't accept the Ferrari
we're always a gross
I grew up of several cars we might one
spin the Ferrari wasn't life